Okay, great. Let's do a quiz having to do with
data consistency. Now in this case, we're going to look at
stock symbols for three different companies over a period of
several years. This is an example drawn from the Bad Data
Handbook. Spencer Burns, in his chapter, When Data and Reality
Don't Match, tells this story having to do with unique identifiers
for a few different companies that are publicly traded. So for
most of the 20th century, stock symbols for Kmart and Sears
were KM and S, respectively. Sprint also, during the time
it was a company during the 20th century, had the stock
symbol, FON, or FON. So now, let's take a look at
what happened with regard to these unique identifiers for companies as
we move forward in time. And, what I want you
to think about is; what type of challenges might this present
to us from a consistency standpoint, and thinking about auditing data
and cleaning data. So, in 2002, Kmart filed for bankruptcy and
was then delisted as a stock. In 2003, they recovered from bankruptcy,
were relisted, but this time with the stock symbol KMRT. In 2005,
Kmart and Sears merged and so all former shares of Kmart
became SHLD, or Sears Holdings, as did Sears stock.
And then later that year, Sprint changed its stock symbol
from FON to S. So, over a period of
several years, three different companies were uniquely identified by
five different stock symbols. And in fact, two companies
were, depending on which point in time you're talking
about, uniquely identified by the same stock symbol. Now
when we talk about these being unique identifiers, we
should really be using air quotes. It's this kind
of problem that we'll often face, when we are looking
at data collected from different points in time.
The identifiers for specific entities have a tendency to
change. Now this type of data is actually
fairly difficult to find. So, in this quiz what
we're going to do is look at something
similar, having to do with when countries joined the
eurozone and what that means for what currency
they were using at a given point in time.